[Musique]
bonjour bonjour aujourd'hui nous vous
présentons le prince des poissons de
rivière c'est le brochet les
mousquetaires connaissait très bien
brochet bien sûr les grands brochet du
rein ou de la loire et puis les branches
les plus petits mets délicieux aussi de
leur région natale de gascogne les
brochets que nous avons sous les yeux
maïté nous avons prévu pour le brochet
de recettes de recettes
une recette très traditionnel oui le
brochet au beurre blanc beur blanc il
nous faut de l'eau du lait du sel et du
citron cela pour faire un court bouillon
court bouillon blanc pour faire le
beurre blanc
il faut du vinaigre blanc du beurre et
des échalotes et les pauvres bien
entendu et les bronches et pour la
recette très très ancienne que nous
allons retrouver qui est un pain de
brochets oui un peu plus compliqué alors
là il faut une béchamel une pâte à choux
de la crème fraîche du beurre débaucher
des champignons de paris d eux et sel et
poivre
eh bien on va essayer voilà et
maintenant on va faire le court bouillon
blanc ou maïté que mettons nous dans
cette fois sony alors ayalon oui les
gens maintenant m et relais oui entre le
marteau voilà on va lui mettre du sel a
certes jasmin où il faut donner du goût
info du brouillon de duroux du poireau
bien sûr carrément qui fait la droite et
les rondelles de citron très bien voilà
dont on a soigneusement enlever la peau
et la faute les tests et les ppp et a
maintenant 20 couvrir on va mettre à
bouillir on veut mettre à bouillir parce
qu'il faudra mettre le poisson à froid à
serait mais il faut qu'ils cuisent bien
encore et c'est chaud voilà remettrait
deux trous
et on va le faire cuire une bonne daube
une bonne demi-heure tout ensemble
le combo lyon est cuit oui il est tout à
fait froid on l'a laissée complètement
refroidir est indispensable ah oui alors
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on va faire il
ya maintenant on va mettre notre brochet
dessus on va lever la grille le brochet
on l'a pendant ce temps-là écailler
évident est évidemment bien entendu
allons reprendre notre brochure en
maîtres sur la grille est tout
simplement pourri on va universal emi le
pavé puisque le congo il ya tout ce
qu'il faut
oui on le remet on remet le couvercle en
appuyant fort longtemps
on va pas laisser bouillir ou du nord va
l'amener à ébullition en éveil tout cela
frise frémir tous deux semaines pendant
20 minutes à peu près parce qu'il est
petit oui le poisson kristen gens qui
m'ont ils sont très bons oui alors on
pourrait peut-être commencer le beurre
blanc le beurre blanc alan par la
casserole
on hamm est évidemment sur le gaz on
vide les échalotes dans cette casserole
savions forêt comme ça qu'on a coupé
très très sereine
on l'aimé et on met notre verre de
vinaigre de vinaigre blanc et on laisse
réduire jusqu'à ce que cela soit c'est
bien réduit puis ça finit par ne plus
rien oui là là le vinaigre plus que
complètement réduit s'est réduit
complètement
est ce qu'on fait on passe alors on va
le passé vous allez me tenir un petit
chinois là et on va bien écraser les
échalotes pour avoir toute banque aux
yeux de finalement un petit peu voila
voila et on passe bien ça n'aurait plus
que le plus prendre des femmes voilà on
appuie ça y est on va bien serré pour
faire bien parce que jules des
échangeurs et et ses nuits c'est terminé
on va remettre le tour laisser ça là je
vais remettre bien nettoyer que sont la
casserole fond de la casserole on va
leur mettre dedans pour qu'il n'ait plus
on va mettre le jus de dans le jugement
était dedans et il faisait les a montées
au bain marie
cette recette et castro là dessus a
chauffé bien entendu on va mettre ce
vinaigre là dedans mais était il faut
peut-être qu'on regarde notre boisson
qui doit certainement être cuit il est
ridicule
dix minutes depuis le moment où sa
cuisine et serait ce qu'un peu trop
parce qu'ils attendent les élèves de 5e
en regardant notre baron notre eau
chaude
on va mettre petit à petit beurre oui
qui ramollit sa verdure là et on va
remuer au bain marie robert mari jan
vesely voilà tout doucement ce très long
à refaire je sais pas c'est long oui et
c'est une source qui fait toujours très
peur aux néophytes parce qu'elle peut
tourner le prochain
ben oui
[Musique]
sur son équipe et il est peut-être temps
de penser à notre pain de broches et oui
c'est une très ancienne recette que nous
avons trouvés dans un très vieux livres
alors pour la faire il faut prendre en
premier la pâte à choux que nous avons
préparé qu'on ne va pas montré à nouveau
puisqu'on l'a montré dans une précédente
émission
c'est toujours à la merci attendre les
recettes patachou partout voilà voilà on
va aimer la besoin de regarder la
recette elle le fait au nez et ça va
superbement ça y est on a joué le
poisson s'étant guère possible un
brochet qu'on a droit au court bouillon
on enlevait les arènes avec grand soin
ce qu'il va facile émiettez émietté
ensuite à manger ensuite nous allons
mettre votre mécha mène notre vie
chamelle
on va paramètres tout car même un petit
peu un petit canard entier voilà on
faire l'oeil toujours eu ce n'est pas la
quantité
bon dieu beurre le baril feu oui et
après on va remuer le tout et les au
silence à valence et paris mais
maintenant je vais avec la fourchette
lyon et pendant que maïté travail
insiste-t-elle vous raconter que le
brochet autant des mousquetaires on en
parlait beaucoup
alexandre dumas son grand dictionnaire
de cuisine rappelle qu en 1749 on avait
repêché dans les eaux du rhin un brochet
qui mesurait 7 mètres de l'eau et qui
pesait 175 kg lorsque la tête et bien
entendu préserver et il existe dans un
musée en allemagne
le brochet au fond assez le requin d'eau
douce sans aucun doute un gros gourmand
mais enfin ils tuent pour se nourrir
alors après tout c'est pour survivre
ça marche je traçais rien voilà c'est
fait très très fort mais qu'est-ce qu'on
agit maintenant le sel le poivre
avant les yeux très bien allez-y pour
saler poivrer on mettra des oeufs après
on va bien parce qu'il faut que soient
relevés quand même toute façon je relève
toujours un peu et un peu plus de sel
parce que rien et ça les voilà et en
continuant à mélanger on va ajouter
ensuite la crème flashy et les jaunes
deux kinés jaune d'oeuf les jeunes de se
brancher d'ailleurs alexandre dumas
raconte aussi qu'il est extrêmement
c'est tout puisque j mr branches et on
dit je ne sais pas enfin une femelle
brochet peut faire
jusqu'à 180 milles eu un buzz au
possible et même des mamans du nominal
et maintenant remettre les yeux les
jeunes doivent les sondeurs jeunes
regardent comme c'est joli comment c'est
très bien là on ajoute les jours de je
vais mettre les blancs là je vais en
mettre trois ou sept et quantité 3e et
alexandre dubard d'ailleurs parle aussi
des pains de poissons dans son grand
dictionnaire de cuisine et il dit que
c'est une excellente manière
d'accommoder les restes non seulement du
brochet mais de beaucoup de bois sur
deux points sont le tout s'est bien
relevé et puis l'a accompagnée d'une
sauce mais ça on le verra qui est à
l'heure voilà et ongle fort mélange le
clown ça aussi je pouvoir 80 d'entre eux
se réveille alors voilà et ensuite vous
allez mettre dans une terrine vic ont
adoré qu'on a beurré à l'avancé à
l'avant et on a fait chauffer notre four
avec un bar avec un bain marie
on en arrive bien entendu le temple à
vélo de danse avance tout le monde s'en
est bien sûr
voilà nous avons juste la quantité
nécessaire pour ce beau moule voilà ce
qui n'est en rien la faille et on va
égaliser un petit peu et il faudra
qu'ils puissent à peu près 45 minutes 45
minutes oui et vous mettez le four chaud
ou moyen courrier à chaud il faut qu'ils
sont chaudes quand même les 60 d'entre
eux se réjouit toutefois la voirie le
maire marie tout est faux voilà et ça y
est eh bien il nous reste plus qu'à
faire une sauce pour accompagner le pain
de poisson le pont brochet alors vous
avez c'est là jamais une béchamel dans
cette baie chamelle je vais y mettre
trois jaunes d'oeuf deux ou trois selon
ebay selon l'épaisseur je remets tout on
va voir au fur et à mesure quoi voilà
trois bières jaune moi j'ai envie
d'arrêter le feu quand même parce que ça
va un peu vite ça va un peu vite alors
un second jaune d'heure et puis on verra
le troisième si c'est nécessaire je
pense pas c'est bien mon avis
ces balles et comme ça ça va très bien
joli très bien maintenant je vais
ajouter ma crème fraîche ou dont 4
cuillères de crème fraîche 2 3 bonne
cuillère bien tassée et pas toujours
besoin de plus voila voila je vais revue
est à nouveau remis large de tous c'est
ce qu'on appelle dans les vieux livres
une sauce crème et on y ajoute on y
ajoute quoi les champignons avec leur
jus on y va alors les champignons les a
fait fuir vous avez montré tout à
l'heure hors écran les a fait fuir avec
du beurre du citron du sel et du poivre
très rapidement et on les ajoute à
l'assaut et on est à jos à la sauce et
ça fait une sauce délicieuse il va nous
accompagner entre poissons voilà et dans
les vieux livres
on y ajoute en plus des 8 et les que des
cris et des queues d'écrevisses j'avais
du grand luxe c'est du grand luxe c'est
très bon comme ça eh bien nous avons
déroulé le pack brochet nous l'avons
décorés oui plaisir et nous avons
présenté le brochet maintenant maïté il
faudrait reprendre nos sources est
peut-être nappes et le bronze en appel
broncher avec le beurre blanc avec de
beurre blanc alors il est bien entendu
que les majorités où il est super un
très joli il est bien entendu que le
brochet on peut le manger chaud au
beurre blanc ou froids veulent manger
avec toute sorte de saut et sa alexandre
dumas nous allons et plein d'idées pour
le brochet rebrancher terminé on pourra
peut-être vous en parlait dans d'autres
émissions toutes ses sauts ce soit faire
maintenant notre sauce à la crème notre
crème
alors s'ils ont relevé deux pas côté à
côté après une sauce crème avec le
chante millions qui va accompagner le
pingouin que la proposition j'ai chaud
froid bien entendu ici il est so or j'ai
fait tomber la rose remettait la rose ou
micheline je remets la rouge
voilà bon alors maintenant on va goûter
maïté le plus important c'est le plus
important on va goûter on va pas défaire
le jolie brune faire on va boucher le
poisson de poissons que je vais vous
servir au pays répond oui très joli je
vous fais plein de sens au dessus un peu
merci l'association pignon
merci mais à présent vous allez vous
dire si c'est bon on pense à vous
allez-y allez-y et moi aussi je vais
goûter lui parce que c'est drôlement bon
c'est drôlement bon oui oui pas
d'égoïsme
je vais faire comme vous un peu de sauce
et on goûte n'ai pas vu beaucoup de sens
et j'espère le meilleur parce que c'est
la raison dans ce film
messieurs reach est quand même oui c'est
une recette d'autres fois c'est vraiment
une recette du siècle dernier à bastia
le rythme se donner c'est délicieux et
ça n'est pas tellement difficile alors
si vous voulez essayer vous nous
écriviez merci beaucoup mais maintenant
c'est mieux encore vous pouvez vous
procurer à fr3 aquitaine les cassettes
de la cuisine des mousquetaires
alors essayez et à bientôt à bientôt à
tous au revoir
[Musique]